today we're going to be speaking with
professor baruch fishoff who is a
professor at carnegie mellon university
where he studies how experts and
non-experts think about
risks it's really great to have you on i
appreciate your time today
oh thanks for having me david so risk is
a very interesting topic because
much like this is a bad analogy but much
like when we come across a yellow light
when driving and we are intuitively
making a number of calculations that
make us decide to either go through the
light or not
we are thinking about the the risks to
us of all sorts of different activities
all the time and
the first part i think maybe that would
make sense to start with is are human
intuition intuitions about risk
generally reliable or
or not so much where we have to
sometimes step back and say am i
actually evaluating this risk correctly
well we're generally pretty good
particularly where we have good sources
of information or we have the same risk
uh see the same risk time and again i
have a chance for trial trial and error
but when something is new and we don't
have unreliable sources then we can uh
you know we can be in trouble
so i would say for example uh pittsburgh
is a has a driving culture where
people run the reds and i grew up in
detroit where people are much more
drivers are much more
disciplined so if i had i have
well-tuned intuitions for detroit
driving took me a while to get right
to uh
adjust them for pittsburgh driving
so
one uh
line that's often repeated for people
who are afraid of flying in on
commercial aviation is you know it's
really safe it's actually more dangerous
to drive to the airport statistically
than the flight itself and then when you
investigate that you find out that well
yes that's that's true in a way but what
it's looking at is based on passenger
miles and because airplanes are much
faster than cars you're traveling many
more miles and maybe
it's true but the the risk difference is
not as big as some might say with
something like that
how is how is the average human
to use that to assess is flying safe
enough for me because most of us don't
think about well what's my risk of dying
per thousand miles driven we just sort
of have a sense of do i know people who
have died in car accidents could i get
into a car accident and survive and most
of us make the decision that we're
willing to drive around but are those
comparisons useful
not really i think just for the reason
that you uh that you cited is that
uh often people who give us those
comparative risk statistics are really
they're trying to work us they're trying
to get us to do something like like fly
or drive or you know wear a mask or wash
our hands or
or whatever it's it's difficult to find
often difficult to find statistics
that are just presented in a trustworthy
way that aren't slanted that are really
relevant to our to our our decision
our decisions and and in situations like
that where really we depend on people to
you know to do that work for us i saw a
report this morning
about some of the things that i wear a
mask still and this is
may 18 may 19th 2022 and that's because
i think there's a lot of uncertainty
about long cove
and there was a long report i think by
well-meaning people with a long report
in one of our major newspapers about
about a study showing that long covid is
very common among relatively young
people
but what they didn't tell us is well how
good is the measurement of non-co
long cove
are the observations for people who've
gotten it from omicron or the earlier
variants where
where the problems were much greater and
then how many people did they have in
each group like in the data set that
they had there were relatively few
people over 60 65
and but that seems to be because they
just didn't have a lot of observations
from people over 65 so it didn't didn't
answer my question what's the chance of
my getting long covered if i um
you know if i'm exposed and it certainly
didn't answer the question of well if i
get long cover what's the chance i'm
going to give it um get covered long
cover i'm going to give it to my wife or
you know or to somebody else so that's
what we really count on the experts to
work up the data in an honest way for us
it turned out to be it requires some
skill
also presenting the data in a way that
it's sort of useful to people seems like
it's a skill
as well i i recently read whether this
is accurate or not it doesn't really
matter but i recently read
that for someone without pre-existing
conditions the risk of dying from covid
is the same as dying in a car accident
for 10 000 miles driven and i was
thinking to myself is that high or low i
don't really know what that is it's sort
of a strange comparison to make how do i
even evaluate that
yeah yeah and and in addition you're
making a dis your risks and benefits are
different in the two
two situations you get some benefit from
taking a long trip you have a different
set of benefits from
you know from um you know making a
statement or having to fight to be the
person who's wearing uh
who's wearing them wearing a mask he
really wants some what you would really
would like is somebody just to give you
the numbers to say
you know if you if you take this trip uh
um you have one chance
an average car trip i think you have
about one chance in 10 million of being
in a fatal accident
and the risk is even smaller if you're
not drinking or driving uh early sunday
sunday morning so give me the numbers
people can handle those numbers and let
me decide don't don't try to work me
can you talk a little bit about when we
measure risk the difference between
absolute and relative risks
right so so something can double your
risk of of uh
of uh you know something terrible
happening to you but it makes a big
difference whether that takes it from
one in a million to two in a million or
from one in a hundred to two and a
hundred so you really need the absolute
numbers the the absolute risk numbers in
order to make the risk benefit uh
trade-offs because you're trading
absolute benefits against absolute
absolute risk so those those relative
risks are really meaningless they're
often misleading
so one example would be in medical
science reporting we often will read
that a certain food for example might
increase the risk or decrease the risk
of say uh you know a type of cancer by
40
and that's a very big number 40 but what
you're saying is it might be the
difference between a lifetime risk of
one percent and 1.4 percent and we need
to have that information to really
accurately assess what it means
exactly i have some friends or
colleagues at the dartmouth medical
school who have developed a drug fact
box like the nutrition fact box that
shows you the probability of things
going right and going wrong if you take
different drugs and absolute
absolute statistics and that's
information even hard for doctors to
know so one of their examples is
is uh
is a sleeping pill and that you find
that people who take the sleeping pill
fall asleep in 37 minutes compared to
people don't take the sleep pill fall
asleep on average in 45 minutes
and then they tell you what are the in
absolute numbers what are the the
side effects with and without the the
well that's that's what you need to know
and and you and i might make those eight
minutes might mean a lot to me and uh
not a lot to you relative to the uh to
the side effects
one of the recent ones speaking of
medications and side effects has been
around covid vaccines uh where there
seemed to be some strange risk i call
them strange i'll see if you agree
strange risk assessments when it comes
to
risks of the vaccine
specifically as compared to risks of
covid so for example
when you considered at one point
myocarditis was one topic that was quite
present and there was a lot of talk of
the risk of myocarditis from the vaccine
and and absent from many of those
conversations was the relative
relatively higher risk of myocarditis
from covid and very often it seemed like
the consideration people were making was
what's my risk of myocarditis from the
vaccine
versus zero when really it should be
compared to the risk from myocarditis
from kovid should it not
oh
exactly and it is it is a persistent
puzzle why
people who are you know very dedicated
to our public health people who are very
dedicated to our health and our safety
and why they don't know that
and and i think i think it's i mean i
have a lot of respect for public health
people
they're dedicated they're often brave
they expose themselves they work long
hours
but but i do they i think they don't
they lack three they get into these
problems three things one is they don't
know how to do risk analysis
the second is that their inclination is
to tell people what to do rather than to
empower people to make their own
decisions and the third is they never
test their messages and if you think
we've got a you know wonderfully
heterogeneous country where people have
different backgrounds and different
different desires you can't imagine a
technical expert can't assume that what
makes sense to them will make sense to
the people that they're talking to and
it it is easy to test your messages like
draft a message
let a few diverse people look at the
message read it
read it aloud tell you whatever comes
into their mind and you're always
surprised by things you thought were
clear that confused them things that
didn't confuse them but they
misinterpreted things that
that you forgot to say that you thought
were common knowledge and things about
your tone that they found disrespectful
where you thought was
i thought it was fine but
you tick them off so it's easy to test
messages they rarely do it
one of the things that relates to risk
assessments
i'm reminded of when years ago i read
the book thinking fast and slow by
daniel kahneman and he talks about a lot
of cognitive biases and heuristics that
affect our thinking about things and
some of them that seem very relevant to
risk assessment would be for example
framing things as the possibilities of
losses versus the possibilities of gains
he did some very interesting work
wherein uh he would sort of set up like
lottery type experiments where in sum
there's a probability of a gain in
others a probability of a loss but the
expected values just thinking
mathematically of these scenarios were
absolutely identical in principle humans
rationally thinking should be
indifferent between these scenarios but
we found out that framing things as
losses versus gains had a major impact
on people's willingness to take risks in
sort of gambling type situations can you
talk a little bit about
real world scenarios not imaginary
lotteries but real world scenarios where
that cognitive bias has a real impact in
people's decisions
yeah so donna kahneman was one of my
doctoral advisors oh no way
along with uh almost
his uh his late late yeah
so uh i even have a cameo role in that
in the in the in the in the book so one
thing to know about the kind of research
that that psychologists do is we look at
situations where people have not figured
out what to do
and those are situations that from a
scientific respect that are revealing a
fundamental thought proce of
cognitive processes emotional processes
where in everyday life those situations
can be fairly rare
that is if you've learned what to do by
trial and error or somebody you trust
has told you what to uh
has told you what what what to do you've
watched what other people do and they
seem to be getting along with things and
uh
and and so on so so the
our research tends to accentuate the
negative because look for problems and
because that's just the way our our
science science goes think a situations
like the pandemic
put us in a situation where we don't
really know what you know where put us
into situations where these kinds of
biases or framing effects are most
effective because we don't really know
what to do we don't really know who to
trust people we talk to have all sorts
of different
different different ideas and
you know one bit of advice is to talk to
different people and
and
they may none of them may know the right
answer but they will they have different
ways of looking at the problem and you
can decide well what way do i want to
frame it do i want to be thinking about
this as a loss or a loss or a gain
another thing a bit of advice i think
like that the literature would i think
support is don't beat yourself up too
much
these are legitimately difficult
decisions partly because they're novel
and the stakes are high but partly
because uh the experts have failed us
they haven't given us statistics that
they want they've manipulated the
statistics as you know as you suggested
uh have you suggested uh
earlier so we're really you know
sort of on our on our own so you know
find somebody who you people you trust
run it by a few other people if you've
done the best you can then things don't
work out you know don't don't add the
insult of of
regret to the injury that you've already
suffered
one really difficult area when it comes
to taking a risk assessment and making
policy and economic decisions
is
really unlikely events
with an absolutely catastrophic impact
where our standard expected value type
calculations might not be very
informative one such would be
you know the
the the number that's often stated is
the odds of a meteor
with at least a one kilometer uh
diameter hitting earth
is basically one every 500 000 years is
when we would expect it now that could
be in two years although maybe astronomy
is good enough that we would know if it
would be in two years but in theory it
could be in two years or it could be in
499
998 years so in such a situation where
it's a very low likelihood but
absolutely catastrophic it can be
difficult
to know how much money should be
invested in technology to save us from
that
should we how much should we invest in
the technology that would allow us to
redirect or blow up such a meteor
how how can humans think about things on
that scale so catastrophic but so
unlikely
yeah i mean one thing to yeah but one
thing to ask is well
well what what would we get for our
money
sure great ideas for what to do about it
then it's a it's a poor investment and
in our own lives if we can't do anything
about it why uh why why worry about it
so sometimes it pays to worry about
relatively small risks if we can do
something to reduce them or can put
ourselves in a situation where we're uh
feel like i've done everything i could
and i'm just gonna hope for the best
yeah i mean i guess the difficulty is
again if we when we start to get to such
large numbers it's sort of like thinking
about a billion years ago and that's
very hard for most
some of these the scale of some of these
things is hard for the average human to
sort of think of or you know a trillion
dollars what does that really mean
relative to the average average annual
budget uh if you if you were to shrink
it down
there's probably some
very small risk when anyone drives a car
not of a car accident but i'm talking
about a mechanical failure that
undetected would almost certainly
explode your car and you could make the
decision to check that thing every time
you drive but none of us really do
because we've assessed the risk is so
small
it
is that a better example to think
through how we would evaluate whether
action or inaction is the right path
yeah if there's nothing you can do
don't worry about it so
people
some i recently saw advice that if
you're really worried about leaving the
gas on
take a picture of your burners before
you leave the house
so there's something you can do it
doesn't right change the risk in case
they were a little ajar but it does put
your mind at ease you
you know with a modern cars you can't
really look under the hood and figure
out whether everything anything is going
wrong you would be fortunate if you're
in a state like pennsylvania that has
mandatory safety checks every uh every
year and we've been doing we've been
here 35 years and every few years they
find something you know that they
wouldn't have known
of otherwise so there's a place where i
think uh you know i think government
coercion as some people would call it
has served us well
very interesting we've been speaking
with professor baruch fishoff who
teaches at carnegie mellon university
really appreciate your time and your
insights today oh thanks thanks for the
conversation